So, how do we use F = ma? Well, let's think of Galileo.
He taught us how to describe motion mathematically.
He discovered that all objects one earth fall at a constant acceleration--10 m/s².
He knew that a free-falling object's distance covered is proportional to time squared.
He sort of answered the how of motion.
Newton, on the other hand, taught us that it's forces that cause motion,
and he represented that with an equation.
He sort of answered the why of motion or at least began to answer the why.
Now, unfortunately, Galileo died shortly after Newton was born,
but Udacity has recently uncovered a series of time traveling text messages
between Isaac Newton and Galileo Galilei.
We were able to recover one screen shot from this incredibly historic
and terribly anachronistic text conversation.
Newton starts by thanking Galileo for giving him some shoulders to stand on.
"No problem," says Galieleo. Wants to know why.
Newton, of course, is getting a little cocky.
Galileo is impressed. Newton tells him about F = ma.
Galileo, of course, immediately understands the consequences.
And then Newton--oh no, we got cut off there.
I guess we'll have to extrapolate and figure the rest out ourselves.